narcissism is is compulsive of self
infatuation so a narcissist is someone
who is metaphorically always looking at
their own image in the mirror of their
own mind narcissism is a is a
psychological disease which which has
become a cultural academic especially
with the emergence of post-modernism so
I'm a baby boomer I'm 56
I grew up in the age of the individual
when I grew up my life was all about me
and our and my generation and our
children's generations are we are very
different than other generations because
we we have grown up in the age where
life is really about me
we were almost conditioned to become and
be very narcissistic when I was when I
was a young boy my parents said
sweetheart you should do whatever is
going to make you happy
and my teachers at school when they say
we spoke about we know what are you
going to do is always well what do you
know what do you what do you want there
was I was never told that you're part of
a bigger context a bigger process that
might need something from you or I was
never told that you know kiddo you're
probably one of the luckiest people
that's ever been born relatively
speaking upper-middle class you know
good education etc you know unparalleled
personal and political freedoms
historically I was never taught that
maybe you have an obligation to help
those who are less fortunate than you so
narcissism is a is a culturally
conditioned epidemic of literally
pathological self concern and so the
experience of the narcissist which is
very common for most many people are
most people from my generation our
children is we think about me all the
time we are always thinking about what
we like what we don't like what we want
what we don't want and so our own egos
fears and desires are of our own egos
become the narrative of our of our
relationship to life it makes us
unknowingly inherently selfish because
we're always thinking about me and we're
always thinking about what's going to be
good for me and what am I going to get
out of
any particular situation it cultivates a
very materialistic relationship to life
even with relationship to people how is
this going to be good for me and when
you awaken beyond this this extremely
narcissistic merry-go-round when you
when you awaken beyond it when you see
beyond experience yourself beyond it it
literally is like coming out of a prison
it's important tension this is not a
personal problem of any particular
individual it's a cultural epidemic and
the only way out of it in my experience
and I've been working on this with a lot
of people for a long time is that the
individual you know you or me as
individuals have to become very
interested very very inspired to to
transcend this this condition otherwise
we probably just not going to do it
because it becomes a it's a emotional
psychological habit this is self
referencing all the times it's becomes
habitual so unless we're very committed
to transcending a compulsively
narcissistic and self-centered
relationship to experience itself we
probably won't undo it